[Music]
so with all the pointless sequels that
Pixar has been making recently finding
dory once again seems like exactly that
a pointless sequel
yeah I guess it is I mean there's
nothing in this movie that's gonna make
me look at Finding Nemo any differently
before a film that doesn't need to exist
I found a surprisingly charming funny
and even kind of touching it just takes
a few minutes to get there the movie
opens up with Dory from the last film
suddenly remembering her family she's
shocked by this because she never
remembers her family in fact even the
first film she said where is her family
she takes this as a sign that she has to
go exploring to locate them this takes
us through honestly a very rushed paced
intro that has a lot of pointless chase
scenes that aren't really that exciting
and truth be told I really thought this
wasn't gonna work based on the first 10
minutes but when Dory gets to an
aquarium sigourney weaver's aquarium
yeah you'll have to see the movie to get
that she comes across all sorts of
colorful characters and yes the leadings
to where her parents might be she comes
across a whale friend who she apparently
did learn well from an octopus that can
blend into any environment and wants to
escape and even Nemo and his dad follow
her to try to help her out and they also
come across a bunch of colorful
characters the fly thing is unlike the
first film where the threat was shards
or jellyfish or any other kind of
monsters in this film the main threat
seems to be anxiety Dory's insecurities
constantly gets the best of her and when
she gets lost or she doesn't know what's
going on you see her start to fall apart
honestly these are both the best and
most stressful parts of the movie we see
this both as an outsider just seeing her
crumble not knowing what to do and from
her own point of view where she just
freezes and everything seems to be a
blur and time seems to move fast and
stay still at the same time these scenes
are very cleverly done but on top of
that it also has the great visuals that
you would associate with the first
Finding Nemo movie the ocean looks
gorgeous these creatures look gorgeous
the aquarium what a great new location
it has a lot of great jokes and it's
just visually stunning
I hit my desk that this character who is
a supporting role in the last movie
could hold her own film but it
surprisingly really works because it
does dive into her real struggles and
shows what she's going through and that
regardless she keeps trying and yes even
keeps on swimmy there's a likable
optimism that you can look up to but
then also this incredible fear that you
can relate to as well in a lot of movies
when a character freezes you just say oh
come on go get out of there stop
standing around doing nothing but here
you understand why it shows why and you
get it what I like too is even though
the movie does repeat a few elements
from the first film it still kind of
feels like its own thing while still
being a true sequel I feel like that can
be summed up in the climax the climax is
funny where the original was really
serious this one is not only really
goofy but has such a strange choice for
a song in such a weird slow-mo way of
doing it that you can't help but smile
with a goofy grin on your face it's so
odd but it's enjoyably odd it's a movie
that's surprisingly won me over and I'd
be more than happy to watch several
times in the future on a side note I
notice in one of these scenes where Dory
is swimming around there's her be in the
background and you can see it's clearly
Herbie it's the Love Bug well this just
got me thinking remember that one movie
where he's trying to throw himself off a
bridge like the car is trying to commit
suicide it might be only one freaked out
that this confirms he finally did it was
the Lindsay Lohan movie really received
that bad I don't know I'm just pointing
out that Disney can have a sick sense of
humor I love it more please well the
first Finding Nemo is technically a
better movie in BO technology character
and story this one's a little bit more
fun
I like the visuals I like the goofy
sense of humor and again I like the way
they show anxiety there's so many
creative approaches in this movie that I
really have a lot of fun with so if you
liked the first one swim on in and check
out the second you surprisingly might
have a good time
you
[Music]